navigating narrow streets of Marseille
emergency crew are faced with a
difficult task of removing Rubble
blocking entry into a collapsed
residential building
we think there might be between four to
ten people under the rubble the fire is
still going on as I speak it's very hard
to access it because the rubble is
blocking access to the fire and of
course we need to get rid of some of the
rubble for safety of the rescue team
with smoke escaping the collapse
building those living on the same street
were forced to leave their homes and are
being put up in local schools until it's
safe to return
the four-story block brought down parts
of buildings on either side on Sunday
priority absolutely our top priority
Remains the search for survivors in the
rubble there's a concern that some
people may have been caught in the first
collapse we're faced with persistent
fire lasting several hours now at
extremely high temperatures we have to
protect our firefighters and sniffer
dogs
Witnesses say it all started when they
heard a loud explosion and smelt gas in
the early hours of the morning
we heard an explosion between midnight
and 1am a very strong one that made us
jump we looked out the window to see
what was happening and we saw Rubble
smoke and people shouting
eight people were killed in Marseille in
2018 when two dilapidated buildings
caved in Aid agencies reported at the
time that 40 000 people in the port city
were living in substandard structures
Bart City officials have ruled out
structural issues in this latest
collapse
Al Jazeera